welcome back ladies and gents today
we're going to talk about highlander the
search for vengeance it is quite a ride
so strap in the movie opens with a dude
on a boat in what looks like an
abandoned jungle this is until the light
turns on and he meets a
vending machine at least we know there's
still coca-cola in this world well sorry
boko caller the guy then hops into what
looks like an abandoned building with
zombies hanging in the air apparently
it's not quite abandoned seeing as tons
of other monsters are all toasting
marshmallows by a campfire it doesn't
exactly take much to scare them off here
he finds a monster named malik who
rightly thought a chainsaw would beat a
sword he was wrong our unnamed hero also
gets a name he's colin for some reason a
huge flash of light appears as malik
dies we're then taken to what apparently
new york city that's seen better days
introduced to us with a guitar riff we
get introduced to what must be our main
villain stroke rival whose guitar is
good but not perfect this world also has
talking rats who can turn into old men
as it happens in anime as colin walks
across a bridge he gets interrupted by
some not so friendly guards in their
robots it appears that colin is a bounty
hunter and a white ted guitar player
doesn't like that he has colin brought
to him in an armored convoy we find out
that a deadly virus killed about 80
percent of the population and the
vaccine is the only thing keeping people
alive now that's some good foreshadowing
for today hey what do you think about
that predictably colin breaks out before
meeting his newest sidekick a little kid
named joe he gets pointed to a shady bar
where we get introduced to dahlia almost
definitely our love interest for this
movie we flash back to colin in his past
meeting a woman much like dahlia called
moya in what looks like the roman empire
after it fell we learned that colin used
to be a brave and respected leader this
is also when he vows his love for the
new woman it's not all rainbows and
sunshine khalid and his band are going
to get wiped out by a gigantic army led
by someone called marcus octavius they
share a drink together but surprise
surprise the drinks doped and he passes
out moya then heads to marcus octavius
who looks exactly like our favorite
guitar player here moya offers to sleep
with marcus if it means sparing her
people from his armies in a shock to no
one she takes the opportunity to stab
marcus who bleeds out on the floor the
only real surprise here is how he didn't
see that one coming in a real twist
however marcus doesn't die catching moya
before she sneaks away from the camp
octavius then ties up moya forcing her
to watch his attack on her people colin
wakes up just in time to watch his men
being slaughtered he manages to weakly
pick up a sword but he isn't in any
shape to use it and he gets trapped
under a falling building his army isn't
doing much better and they get ruined
colin though somehow survives waking up
to the wreckage of what used to be his
people in the distance he sees moyer
still hanging atop the corpses of his
people he rushes to her maybe hoping
she's alive she's barely hanging on and
makes colin vow not to seek revenge he
reluctantly agrees just as moya finally
dies in his arms well the twist here is
colin swears to seek revenge we cut back
to colin in the bar the scene obviously
drawing a parallel between dahlia and
colin the police are searching for him
and he follows dahlia to safety inside a
ruined church dalia then recruits colin
to help her save the city then we see a
government-controlled area with some
government officials talking about
expanding their rule further we find
that octavius is the commander and is
forcing his scientists to come up with
some dangerous weapons the police search
the city as colin hides in a ruined
subway a secret entrance leads them to a
rebel hideout it seems like a decent
enough place minus the rat soup we
learned that the vaccine is only
administered to people living in the
tower and everyone else must get by
dahlia takes colin to a home apparently
so he can pay to have sex with her colin
turns her down knowing there are strings
attached dalia wants him to help her
steal vaccines and colin leaves her
place we catch up with them above ground
where colin finds out that marcus is the
one who's been running the city we flash
back again to colin in the past storming
a roman outpost to find marcus again he
kills a guard and dons his uniform
before finding the man himself colin
manages to sneak up to his tent before
he starts having a seizure he eventually
recovers himself and charges mark but
he's more than a little outnumbered and
gets overwhelmed marcus challenges him
to a fair duel and the two charge each
other in the middle of a field despite
his best efforts marcus gravely injured
him and chased him down colin collapses
in stonehenge and marcus gives up on him
his wounds eventually heal and he
revives to meet a spirit called armagon
who tells him he's immortal colin blows
him off but a lightning bolt falls on
him showing him that he's immortal but
not invincible then they talk armagan
tells him that the romans have long
since perished but the marcus is an
immortal who's much stronger than colin
amragan tells him that immortals get
stronger by beheading other immortals
and taking their energy in what's called
a quickening most importantly though
colin is now infertile ouch colin still
wants revenge and we return to modern
times now he's more than willing to help
dahlia infiltrate the tower the two use
a hidden entrance to infiltrate the
place and there are a lot of them around
they run into joe who insists on tagging
along joe's alarm rings off waking what
can only be described as a giant demon
crocodile connie makes short work of the
monster beheading it and saving dania's
life by a second the three run into a
patrol and colin charges in rather than
waiting to sneak in he easily takes down
the guards before the trio stumble into
what looks like a laboratory dania holds
them all at gunpoint forcing them to
give her the vaccine they're working on
something but a lead scientist is acting
more than a little bit suspicious
they've been working on a perfect virus
one that can't be vaccinated against
apparently these people were the ones
behind the pandemic and dalia knocks the
creepy guy out colin senses marcus and
leaves the other two to go fight him
again he takes what must be the biggest
elevator on the planet to get to him we
flash back to colin in the past again
charging into what looks like a coliseum
here rather than helping a woman and her
child he senses octavius and confronts
him again octavius gives a long-winded
speech before the two trade blows once
again colin is no match for him writers
is about to be beheaded some soldiers
charge in forcing marcus back we cut to
another battlefield then another each
time colin tries to find marcus trying
to get his revenge every time he fails
every time he builds a new life for him
before dying for revenge he eventually
revives trying to do it all over again
one time he gets confronted by men who
saw him dead and they tried to kill him
he only gets let off thanks to their
leader vouching for him this is where he
gets the name highlander as he lives his
life all over again for a thousand years
he tried to get his revenge he confronts
marcus in what looks like japan once
again not being any match for him this
time he survives as a falling building
separates the two we even see him as a
pilot in world war one jumping onto
marcus's plane before it blows up he
wakes up again in a church holy ground
where marcus can't touch him even marcus
starts to wonder if colin has done
anything in the last 2000 years marcus
advises colin to find something else in
his life positive for a psychopath we
cut again to modern times as dani and
joe are still trying to make their
escape dalia manages to jump away to
safety and finally colin confronts
marcus again marcus effortlessly dodges
all of colin's blows before being
taunted and thrown back they have
another exchange of blows before marcus
throws colin through a window and runs
him through with his sword the two then
have a jewel on the side of a tower
before marcus throws colin from the top
of it he lands right in front of dahlia
and joe joe leaves with a vaccine as
dahlia surveys his dead body as she
tends to leave colin comes back to life
dahlia drags his mangled body out of the
tower as colin finally lets her know
about why he's here and why he wants to
kill marcus in the first place the two
almost get stopped by some guards who
thankfully have the worst aim i've ever
seen dahlia blows up the tunnel with a
grenade before escaping she collapses on
the ground before pondering over how
much colin has gone through we see colin
in his mind talking to armagom he stands
by her grave as armagh talks about how
moya has reincarnated through the ages
but colin has been too single-minded to
see it her song is in dalia right now
colin wakes up in their hideout his
injuries healed everyone's shocked at
his recovery but it gives them hope that
even the impossible is possible
everyone is rallied to go to war against
their oppressors dalia doesn't want
colin to fight but he takes up the sword
anyway we cut back to marcus who finds
that the newest virus is now defective
he sends his people to suppress the
rebels we see dalia in her room as colin
seeks her out he thanks her for what she
did for him and dahlia reasserts her
willingness to fight despite not being
immortal the two make love as dalia
sleeps colin locks her room intending to
keep her safe the government army
patrols the street as the rebels watch
colin asserts that the only way to win
is to kill marcus as the rest have to
buy time joe shows him another hidden
entrance to the tower the rebels first
shot missed and the fighting starts
dahlia wakes up to find herself locked
in her room she eventually manages to
break through as colin tries getting
into the tower again he has to run
through a small army but he manages with
some sneaky and all he would have before
marcus's assistant finds him in a
helicopter there's an explosion and
marcus uses it to run he gets chased by
the assistant and dahlia manages to
knock her chopper out of the sky she
dies from a hail of bullets as dahlia
buys time for her the two professed
their love as colin goes to fight marcus
the rebel who missed before finally
manages to hit the slowest moving tank
ever dozens of rocket launchers all aim
at the tower at the top marcus and colin
confront each other marcus claims he'll
use the virus to kill everyone in two
minutes unless colin can stop him the
two fight and colin is outmatched big
surprise there time ticks down and colin
fails to disarm the virus in time even
as marcus impales him dalia gets impaled
by the assistant who's managed to come
back to life the rebels all start to die
from the virus dahlia shoves a grenade
into her mouth before she dies taking
them both out colin realizes she's died
and finds one last push to stand up the
two fight and colin finally puts marcus
on the back foot before snapping his
sword and beheading him shock waves
destroy both the tower and the army the
quickening manages to wipe out the virus
too saving the rebels colin likes a
candle for dahlia before leaving again
then the credits roll
that was quite the movie now wasn't it
we hope you enjoyed the video don't
forget to leave a like and subscribe to
the channel oh and leave future movie
suggestions down in the comments too
peace